Martin gets back to Brown here's Tatum
fires over and beat got it
finally Tatum connects from Deep
frustration after frustration a great
defender in your grill they get the
switch maxion Tatum now
a quick set triple Tatum that's two in a
row Jason Tatum welcome to Philadelphia
homely drill a three and against a tough
closeout back to back wow unshakable
belief for the longest stretch of this
game it was miserable he's got 11 of
their last 13. you trust the work I've
been here before JT on time
unshakable belief for the longest
stretch of this game it was miserable
he's got 11.
Tatum slips out fires the three made two
in a row make it three Jason Tatum not
always there when you call but always on
time starting to feel like this one is
really over now yeah doc was trying to
give them the foul
tayden with the three that one Falls 16
points in the fourth quarter
was materializing it felt almost
pre-ordained to be another epic classic
the most played playoff series in NBA
history they've met 22 times and it will
come down to 48 minutes in Boston the
Two Jays
smoke in that Philadelphia path tonight
it's over